i know usually we [ __ ] around stuff this
isn't a funny story in anything i wanted
to ask you yeah because i heard a little
something through the grapevine but i
don't know what happened
so that's why i called you to see if you
were i know and i was like i'll tell you
on the show yeah because i don't want to
keep repeating this story um
so on thursday night a little date night
meanwhile for a little date night we are
going to meet our friends at scopa yeah
so we're driving to the west side and
we're we're driving down there went off
the 101 right by encino
and my girl goes oh holy [ __ ] babe slow
down slow down you go what she goes
there's an accident they look that 18
wheeler so the 18 wheeler's like like
this like the front knife like that and
then it's like this so it's cut off the
two nearest lanes we're like what the
[ __ ] so my guy would just go around so
we're going around and there's a car
just mangled and there's a
seven-year-old a six or seven because i
have kids right there's like a six or
seven year old on top of the car like
this
like this yelling for help so i'm like
babe oh that's a [ __ ] kid and she's
like just keep going like no it's a it's
a kid and then he's pointing down i look
in there's two other kids in the car
so i pull up there's like debris
everywhere i pull up i get out i go i
told my girl i go do not get out of the
car stay here because because you know
my family chp and he says never pull
over an accident it's too dangerous
never ever people get [ __ ] up all the
time but i thought because the 18
wheeler was blocking the lanes we had
some protection
so i get out
and i'm i'm running towards the kids and
it's probably i don't know not close
because i had to go past all the debris
and stuff because the car's hitting
debris is like flying everywhere so i
pulled pretty far up
so i'm running towards the mangled car
and i see a guy with no shoes on he's in
a wife beater like kind of out of shape
mexican run across the 101. i'm like
what the [ __ ]
i'm looking and then a dodge durango
probably going 60 miles an hour
whack
hits him and i'm like what in the [ __ ]
is going on man and he's on the ground
like rolling like this i don't think
thing over i'm like what in the [ __ ] man
so i'm just thinking about the kids
so i keep going and that 18-wheeler
where the car hit it hit the gas they
hit the gas tank so 18 wheelers have all
the gas in the world so there's
a flow of gas this as thick as this room
fly flooding out so my shoes my jeans
are all covered with gas because i'm
running so the gas is sprayed so it
smells so much like gas oh my god this
isn't safe in my head i'm like [ __ ] i
have kids man i can't go out like this
but i'm thinking of those kids
that guy who got hit pops up and then
crosses the other lanes but as he pops
up i'll never he looks he like looks at
me and has this crazy look in his eyes
and i'm like what in the [ __ ] is up with
that man
i get to the car the car's all [ __ ]
mangled and there's one other guy there
who's on the scene maybe he's the truck
driver i'm not sure but me and him are
the first on the scene
and there's two kids and there's the oh
i'm gonna try this without crying
there's a bigger kid and he keeps going
i don't want to die i don't want to die
you're not going to die buddy you're not
going to die and i tell the guy i'm like
back up back up
so i grabbed the door and i'm trying to
[ __ ] but it's mangled from the crash
so it's like intertwined with the with
the car so i'm like back up i'm trying
to pull down i can't so i go we gotta
smash this window and get them through
the window so i break the window we
break some of the window out sorry broke
i'm not like [ __ ] captain america so
i i'm pulling all the shattered glass
and i take the kid through so the big
big kid he's like out of shape like kid
who kept going out i don't want to die i
want to die
this little brother who's probably
two and a half or three
i unbuckle him i get him out of the car
and i look at the other guy and i go
he's there anybody in the car and he
goes there's i think there's one other
person in the front
so i'm grabbing the kid i go it's all
right bubba it's all right and then i
look
and then the front is a
lady who passed away
um brain matter everywhere blood
everywhere and the kid's going mama mama
and i go
i go bubba look at me
look at me look at me look at me don't
look over there because he was so young
it would have completely [ __ ] them up
so i go look at me don't look over look
at me i look at the ego get a blanket
cover his mom
and there's a lady walks up i don't know
where she came from
and i go take these two kids and run
that way run away from the car and she
goes well i think it's better to go that
way don't go that way because the mom's
there they can't see the mom go that way
and so i sprint back i sprint back to my
car
and my my girl's like she's all freaking
out stuff like that so i get in the car
and we're going i have blood on my shirt
and stuff like that
and so i was a little mad at myself for
you know putting my girl in that
situation then i have kids i'm like man
what the [ __ ] am i doing and so i was a
little mad
and then you know my father-in-law chp
i call him and tell him i'm like you
know i was the first on the scene but i
didn't stick around because it's so
dangerous and you know hopefully i don't
get in trouble for it but if you need
any witnesses i saw it all and he was
okay we'll keep you posted they're gonna
need your uh report the little kid that
was on the top of the car what happened
he was fine he came around okay and i
kept telling my go dude you're a badass
you're you're such a badass dude you're
so brave man
i said you're so brave dude you're such
a little badass man i'm so proud of you
i know you don't know me i'm so proud of
you dude because you're the reason i
stopped and i got your brothers i said
i'm so [ __ ] proud of you
so the lady took the kids
and then
you know uh get a call from uh the lapd
chp after that give them whatever
everything i saw
i said what the [ __ ] happened man
and they said that guy that you saw that
hit by the car that morning woke up told
those kids we're all going to heaven
today
and he got on uh havenhurst
to get on the 101 went into traffic
and decided he was going to kill the
whole family and run into 18 wheeler and
so they the driver of the 18 wheeler
goes yeah i saw the car come in and i i
veered i was like what the [ __ ] i veered
right and he veered right i veered left
he veered left and he just ran into me
well that [ __ ] idiot that dad who
wanted to kill the whole family
obviously he didn't die and then um
the kids didn't die just just the the
mom died just the mom died
so i was like all right we gotta we we
gotta do i gotta do something i could i
can't say i can't sleep you can't sleep
all i remember is that lady man like
i've seen movies and you know you think
movies
until you [ __ ] see it man i can't get
on my head so i haven't been able to
sleep that's why dude your eyes are red
i can't look you look
i keep thinking about kids keep thinking
about the kids and then um
a friend of mine sent me their gofundme
because i was like we gotta do something
to help these kids like
so this is the mom so this is what on
the gofundme so and this just for the
funeral cost they're trying to raise 30
000 they have 20 20 400 right now so it
says on thursday august 12th my niece
amy garcia who's 26 was killed in a
wrong way dr driving collision with the
big rig on the 101 freeway in encino
she leaves behind four beautiful
children all under the age of eight she
was loving karen mother unfort
unfortunately she was a victim of
domestic violence for many years and
yesterday the aggressor fulfilled his
objective and entered the freeway the
wrong direction
intentionally killing my niece thank god
the children are fine but very
traumatized
we're asking for help for burial
expenses anything you can do to help us
will be greatly appreciated rest in
peace my dear amy you will be terribly
missed
so i reached out to the aunt because
i'll help pay for the funeral i told her
i'll help pay for the funeral but i'm
going to help those kids out man how do
you help the kids out so i sent her an
email
uh oh and you know hopefully she gets
back to me on that i don't know what you
do like think think and i was talking
about an educational friend of somebody
i thought yeah something i was talking
about everybody
yes
i saw everybody taught about it
he was like well one thing to make you
feel better
you got to feel like in that household
if the dad was that [ __ ] up yeah he
wanted to kill that entire family yes
and domestic abuse those kids are so
much better off without that dad i mean
their mom who knows what was going on
there but without that dad so hopefully
these kids because they weren't gonna
have a shot to get from the jump with
that shitty dad the question is who
raises them now you know that that's
what i'm getting at obviously has an
aunt they have an aunt whose rate did
this hopefully have grandma grandpa and
maybe help them out
figure out a way to help them out with
them
help them out like you know where
you can raise a lot of money with just
one show and we can get a lot of people
i can raise money for them yeah i can do
that and and then maybe just to help out
because that's four extra kids in a
household right so
you want to keep the kids together under
the same the gofundme i don't mind but
it's for the funeral costs you know 30
grand but it's like
you know that's one she's passed away
but it's like those kids and what we
should be raising money for yeah so
that's in some way you can donate to the
gofundme there to hit their mark and
then hopefully i can figure out a way to
get a hold of them you did a good thing
dude yeah
you know man thank god you did it
because that you're not saying who was
it who said that if not if not you who
if not now when
sometimes you know that's a very apt
thing to ask yourself and i don't know
what would happen to those kids maybe
that that gasoline would have got to
them or the dad comes back or the dad
comes back or whatever but i wish i
would have known okay i wish i would
have known that dad was such a piece of
[ __ ] i wish i would have known that was
going on yeah he'll be dealt with in his
own way that that guy's that guy's
got his own demons obviously and he's
a real piece of [ __ ] yeah